another new leader in the UK Britain's
third prime minister in a year of
political chaos he is now promising a
new era of stability former Finance
Minister Rishi sunak today gained the
backing of his conservative party to win
the leadership of that party his
predecessor Liz trust she had to stand
down when financial markets rejected her
economic plans sunac's first task will
be to restore confidence in the UK
government's finances
receives a warm welcome his cheered and
greeted at the conservative party
headquarters
sonak will take over the top job from
less stress who quit just after a few
weeks in office
but sonak faces tough challenges such as
tackling soaring energy and food prices
and a deep political crisis he will be
the third prime minister this year
the United Kingdom is a great country
but there is no doubt we Face a profound
economic challenge
we now need stability and unity and I
will make it my utmost priority to bring
our party and our country together
as Finance Minister sonak earned priests
for supporting the lead of workers and
businesses during the pandemic
but as one of the wealthiest politicians
in the UK he has also been criticized
for his lavish lifestyle especially at a
time when Ordinary People are struggling
but sonak's Victory is also historic he
is the first British Prime Minister of
South Asian origin he is also the first
Hindu to become the country's leader and
the youngest the UK has seen in 200
years
I'm joined by Nicholas Allen he's a
professor of politics at the Royal
Holloway University in London it's good
to have you on the program with us let
me ask you considering what we've seen
in these past few months is there reason
to believe tonight that Rishi sunak will
be UK prime minister for longer than 45
days
I think there's a good chance that he
will last longer than this trust it's
almost impossible for him not to last
longer I think the likelihood of him
inflicting economic catastrophe uh on
himself
um I don't think that's going to happen
so the the
self-inflicted problems that this child
support have called upon herself that
ended her Premiership that's not going
to happen and the other thing that
Cinder Acosta his Advantage is I think
the MPS in the conservative party just
know they are now in The Last Chance
Saloon and they'll give him a little bit
of a ride a little bit of an easy
passage at least to start with so I
think he should be on course to last a
bit longer for trust you know only seven
weeks ago Britain's conservatives they
chose Liz trust over Rishi sooner and
yet at the time that he lost that race
he was warning that this mini budget
which we we know trust proposed could
have dire consequences then that is
exactly what happened he could have said
today I told you so but he did not what
message does that send
I think he has a difficult path to tread
his criticisms of Liz truss's economic
policies the program on which she was
actually elected by conservative party
members he doesn't even need to point
out that she got that wrong because
everyone can see it and already the
second chance appointed second Finance
Minister Jeremy Hunt reversed those
policies so I think sunac doesn't need
to say I told you so because everyone
knows that he told us so so I think um
in that sense
in his pursuit of unity within the party
he can afford to speak very softly shall
we say in terms of criticizing his
predecessor yeah and pick up on the word
um afford
um sunac is fantastically wealthy he's
one of the richest people in the UK um
he was involved in his own tax Scandal
earlier this year
is there going to be a a large Chasm for
him to bridge between himself and
ordinary britons right now who many who
are just I'm struggling you know to deal
with inflation
foreign
conservative politicians are probably
perceived more or less as being out of
touch with ordinary voters so in the
sense he's not in any different position
to anyone else
clearly his enormous wealth is something
that
his opponents might want to use their
advantage in terms of criticizing
highlightings highlighting his being out
of touch but I don't think he per se is
going to be any more out of touch with
what voters think than Sailors trust I
mean not least is he is a constituency
MP he is expected and does keep in touch
with his constituents and his
constituency parties so
he's going to have his finger on the
pulse as much or as little as really any
other conservative minister
Nicholas Allen professor of politics at
the Royal Halloween University of London
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thanks well for morning Al I'm joined by
Roger casala he's a former member of
parliament for the labor party in the UK
he now lives in Italy Roger it's good to
have you back on the program it's good
to see you again
um let me ask you about what's happened
here we've had three UK prime ministers
in less than two months time we've had I
think four finance ministers in four or
five months I mean it's been said this
week that British politics now looks a
lot like Italian politics you live in
Italy now what do you say about your
home country from your Vantage Point
well it looked good evening great great
to see you yeah it looks like a old
style Italian politics but new style of
Italian politics seems to be much more
stable so you say four finance ministers
three prime ministers don't forget
Britain has also had two monarchs in the
last two months and it's had the mother
of all Financial crises and it's a very
uh unusually uh volatile time for all of
British institutions at the moment uh
and I think that's face people it's uh
it's it's very unusual and uh politics
is is not like bungee jumping you know I
think sometimes people think from the
outside that's what it can look like you
might should lead us up to the top of
the platform and throw them off again
and see what happens but of course
people don't want that happening with
their lives and I think that
um from the point of view of the public
from the citizens of the UK it's a
worrying time it's an anxious time very
very unstable and they want forms the
critical leaders and they want the
political system to get a grip
I want to ask you about the incoming
government's legitimacy firstly take a
listen to what your former party the
opposition labor party what they're
saying about this incoming government
take a listen
everybody who I've spoken to the public
have said we should be having a general
election there is no mandate now the
conservatives are completely broken
their promises broke our economy and now
they want to see a general election they
can't just keep Doling out Prime
Ministers every month because they're in
total chaos and they've lost control of
the market and haven't got any ideas of
how they're going to tackle the cost of
living that people are facing I mean
she's very clear about where she stands
polls also show that a new election
would be a disaster for the
conservatives so it's not in their
interest to call Early elections is it
would it be in the country's interests
well remember that when Gordon Brown
took over from Tony Blair there was not
a general election so you don't have to
have a general election when you change
the prime minister in the UK but you can
see the argument for it given the the
the situation that we're in and the fact
that we've had uh so many changes of
prime minister but the conservatives
still have a big majority in the House
of Commons and they're not going to go
to the poll to the polls call an early
election when the polls put labor so far
ahead and the problem that uh Rishi
sabnac is it's not just about his uh
legitimacy it's political legitimacy
it's also about The credibility of the
conservatives and that's what he wants
to reestablish first
the conservatives uh economic
credibility it's reputation for being
competent with the economy it's been
completely shattered and Russia's sooner
will try to rebuild that but in
rebuilding that I think there is a
danger for him in that he he will
espouse a very difficult economic
measures and that will bring further
unpopularity so I think what will happen
is that he will continue through to 2024
and then the probably the next Hospital
down the street would be the leader of
the naval party kierstama because the
tough mate they're unpopular at the
moment and the policies that we see now
will have to adopt and re-establish The
credibility and the and to make the
economy work will be unpopular what
we've heard from leaders across Europe
that what's most important is for
stability to be restored in the UK we
heard that from the president of France
just a couple of days ago would um prime
minister
um sunak is he going to be the the
person who can do that is he going to be
the right partner for Europe
well that is well that's what he's going
to try to do and I expect that's what he
he will do and it won't make him popular
I think as far as Europe is concerned
I'm glad you mentioned the European
issue because that I think probably
enough is at the heart of the province
of the conservative party is facing the
Britain is facing today because your
viewers will know that the referendum
took place a long time ago and they
always say well why are people still
talking about brexit and they're not
really still talking about brexit but
brexit isn't really done the
conservative party has got to
articulate a vision for Britain's future
post brexit and it has been unable to do
that and there are two contrasting views
within the conservative party about what
that vision for Bryn's future looks like
on the one hand the so-called Singapore
on the Thames very free market view that
is trust in her supporters had which has
been jettisoned now has been seen off
because there is an absolute disaster
and on the other the hand of the view
that perhaps was more Boris Johnson with
some people around Boris Johnson but you
needed to focus on the domestic economy
and I think
he's got a difficult job to To Tread a
middle wave and to restore the uh
credibility of the economic credibility
of the conservative government while
managing these contrasting tensions
within the inventory party about what a
post-brexit Britain should look like and
I think it's very difficult to see how
you can resolve those tensions yeah and
you know what you're describing here is
that maybe the cursive brexit which you
know you discussed with me many times
going all the way back to that
referendum back in 2016. Roger Castle is
always good talking with you we
appreciate your time tonight thank you
thank you Ben